In all the studies of procrastination, what
they’ve basically said are two things: number
one, you can’t find some work reward that’s
going to take the place of procrastination.
Right?
If the reward for procrastination is that
you get to spend five minutes distracted by
Facebook, you have to allow yourself to do
that.
That has to be part of your work day.
If you need five minutes every hour to look
at tweets or to just surf the internet, you
need to schedule that into your schedule,
allow yourself to do that.
Because when people start procrastinating,
what they’ve done is, they’ve tried to
ignore that urge.
They try to deny themselves time on Facebook
or time surfing the web.
And then all of a sudden, it erupts and
they go and they say, I’m just going to
check for five minutes, and 45 minutes later,
they’ve lost, you know, all of this time.
It’s because they haven’t accommodated
that need.
Again, once the habit exists, you can’t
just quelch it.
You can’t pretend it’s not there.
You have to sort of accommodate this need
in your life.
And so the answer is, to give yourself five
minutes every hour.
In fact, you can set an alarm at the end
of every hour give yourself five minutes to
surf the web.
Because if you allow yourself five minutes
every hour, it won’t explode into 45 minutes
because you’ve been trying to suppress it.
But the other thing we also know, and this
is very interesting, and this is something
I actually found when writing the book.
The more you focus, the more that focus
becomes a habit.
So, willpower is like a muscle, right?
It’s this muscle that you can build up,
and it gets tired, but the more you exercise
it, the stronger it gets.
The same is true of our ability to focus.
The more you practice focusing, the easier
focusing becomes.
And so the other answer for procrastination
is, don’t beat up on yourself.
Let yourself practice going longer and longer
and longer without taking a five-minute break
to check Facebook because after three or four
weeks, after three or four months you’ll
be able to sustain focus much longer, but
the key is, you can’t change everything
overnight.
You can’t suddenly say, I want a brand
new habit tomorrow and expect it to be east
and effortless.
It’s something you have to give yourself
permission to take a little bit of time to
practices because you’re building up neuro
pathways associated with certain behavior
and those neuro pathways just build up over
time.
You can’t speed up that process any more
than is natural.